back here in nevada our unemployment
remains pretty high
a lot of companies are hiring right now
and if you're looking to get back into
the workforce but maybe you want a
career change
now is the perfect time we're wrapping
up our back to work week here in good
day las vegas with jose bello from the
one stop career center jose thank you
very much just this morning for joining
us to try and help folks find that
perfect job good morning to you
good morning thank you for having me so
uh what are you seeing in terms of
people looking to try and maybe make a
change a lot of folks either lost their
jobs or were laid off furloughed during
the depths of the pandemic
now they're trying to get back into the
workforce what kind of a change are they
looking for
uh absolutely ever since the pandemic
hit we have seen an
influx of job seekers in our community
looking
to either redefine their skills or
obtain new ones uh
we have also seen a lot of people
looking to
go into a new career as well but they
aren't 100 sure of what they
want to go into you know i think a lot
of folks when we've talked about it
earlier this week
about retraining themselves and learning
new skills it seems so
daunting to just retrain your brain your
skill set
what how challenging really is for
someone who's at home to maybe switch
from working in the resort industry to
doing something completely different or
vice versa
yeah it's actually not very difficult at
all we actually offer a
the community a tool called tradify
think of it like a
personality test that will match your
interests and skills to possible careers
you can just sign up for a free account
and this is a resource that we provide
for free
to our southern nevada residents yeah i
was going to ask you about this online
career personality test i think i
remember taking one of those when i was
in high school when i was
they were trying to find out what what
job you might want when you grow up
uh how crucial is it to really know what
you want to do
before you go back into the workforce so
you're more specific in trying to
to find a career absolutely it's a
hundred percent going to put you ahead
of the job market to know
what you want to do and what skills are
needed to
actually obtain the career um
this assessment and it's only about 90
seconds and i think you may have a video
of what the assessment actually looks
like
uh the tool essentially what you will do
is it will show you a series of photos
and you simply click on me or not me
and based on those photos you're what
you're doing is you're giving the
software an idea of your likes and
dislikes
it then takes that information and
develops a personality plan for you
and breaks down your traits and what
they mean and it's pretty accurate and
fun of course
the best part about it is that you can
see your career matches and kind of
see your top 10 and click on them and
see if you like them or you don't like
them
and kind of see how many job openings
there are in the area for it as well
all right so yeah you have the test
results jose then you
how can one stop how can you help folks
get from the test results
to maybe a new job and a career in the
valley well you come see us
of course uh you know our one-stop
career centers we are always happy to
help our job seekers in our community
we do both virtual and in-person
services and our help is always at 100
no cost to you
uh you can also check out job
opportunities at employeemb.gov
some of you may recognize this as the
pua website if you file for unemployment
within the last year or so
but it's actually the large the state's
largest online source for
job positions uh you can search for jobs
based on a variety of criteria like job
title
industry locations and it's completely
free to use to
pull job seekers and employers one of my
favorite things on it is the
resume building tool yeah and we had
someone from one stop in earlier this
this week talking about that as well
jose bello thank you very much for
talking about this test is really
interesting even if you have a job just
kind of playing around with it might be
kind of fun to do and just kind of learn
a little bit about yourself so
thank you for joining us this morning
jose and have a good rest of the day
appreciate it
thank you for having me for a full list
of other companies that are hiring in
the valley right now just go to
eightnewsnow.com
you can click on the job board tab we
have a list and links to apply
all for you there